ciao a tutti io vorrei parlarvi di
energia e di risorse e di come ce la
procuriamo prendiamo ad esempio questo
teatro questo teatro ha bisogno di
essere scaldato ecco il metano che
usiamo per scaldarci quella molecola che
brucia nella caldaia viene da 8.000
chilometri di distanza km nemmeno facili
e probabilmente è passata attraverso
l'ucraina
e comunque ci viene consegnata a casa
noi la bruciamo con una fiamma a mille
gradi per produrre aria calda a 20 gradi
8000 km mille gradi e il prodotto finale
aria calda a 20 gradi
esiste una grandezza in fisica che si
chiama exergia che ha a che fare con
l'entropia il caos misura la quantità di
energia disponibile in una
trasformazione
diciamo un po la la qualità dell'energia
ecco la combustione del gas per fare
riscaldamento è un suicidio e sorge tico
una forma molto nobile e densa di
energia un combustibile fossile il
metano che ha impiegato milioni di anni
per formarsi bruciata per produrre una
delle forme di qualità e alla qualità
energetica più bassa aria a 20 gradi
e poi non ci dimentichiamo che quella
molecola diventare una volta bruciata
libera anidride carbonica in atmosfera e
quindi effetto serra ma ad esempio come
questo se ne possono fare un milione voi
pensate che usiamo acqua potabile
carissima per tirare lo sciacquone
e quindi quello che voglio dire è che
spero di aver seminato il dubbio che
questo modo di approvvigionarsi delle
risorse non sia molto efficiente e non
sia sostenibile e quindi noi per 50 anni
negli ultimi 50 anni abbiamo delegato la
nostra energia quotidiana a reti
infrastrutture esterne in cambio di
bollette e del tempo libero rubato per
trovare i soldi per pagarle queste
bollette
l'impressione è che qualcosa stia
scricchiolando qualcosa scritto lì che
ci si faccia qualche domanda in più
che cosa succede se non abbiamo modo di
pagarle queste bollette che cosa succede
se queste reti esterne a cui ci siamo
affidati crollano per qualche attenzione
internazionale oppure perché anche per
qualche evento naturale estremo come si
può essere autonomi e davvero
sostenibili la riflessione che voglio
farvi è questa se io uso esclusivamente
le risorse che ricadono all'interno del
mio territorio e devo fare i conti con
gli scarti che ricadono sullo stesso
territorio
allora starò naturalmente attento a non
sprecare niente ma non degradare niente
in modo irreversibile
sarei autonomo e sostenibile questo è il
paradigma off grid off grid vuol dire
distaccati dalle reti dell'elettricità
del gas e dell'acqua vuol dire
riappropriarsi della generazione della
nostra energia e delle nostre risorse e
quindi essere off grid e oggi è
possibile anzi tecnicamente è abbastanza
facile e le fonti rinnovabili in questo
giocano un ruolo fondamentale acqua sole
vento e legna sono risorse
se integrate e non sprecate e
contribuiscono anzi sono sufficienti a
rendere autosufficienti la maggior parte
dei territori abitati da dall'uomo
allora che cosa impedisce il passaggio a
questo modo diverso di approvvigionarsi
delle risorse inevitabilmente ci sono
delle barriere alcune di tipo culturale
e sociale altre di tipo tecnico ed
economico
partiamo dalle prime innanzitutto c'è un
problema di consapevolezza di conoscenza
ossia non a tutti è noto che è possibile
vivere off grid e o come farlo oppure
anche vivere in prospettiva off grid ed
è anche il motivo per cui mi trovo qui
per dire che è possibile farlo che non è
la sceneggiatura di qualche film
catastrofista è anche il motivo per cui
nel gruppo con cui con cui lavoro
abbiamo creato una ospita accademy
rivolta a tecnici ma anche a persone
comuni dove si insegna come integrare le
fonti rinnovabili e come ad esempio
costruire un orto sinergico
poi c'è una naturale propensione del
sistema a mantenere lo status quo che
sia una volontà politica oppure
economica ecco lo script in questo ha il
vantaggio di poter essere una
rivoluzione che parte singolarmente e
dal basso e può cominciare ed è
cominciata da singole abitazioni o
comunità che possono decidere di
staccarsi dalle reti per poi diffondersi
poi come vi dicevo ci sono anche delle
barriere economiche ossia di qui il
discorso è molto lungo e complesso
non c'è sicuramente tempo per farlo però
voglio solo far vedere una tendenza che
quella del prezzo dei pannelli
fotovoltaici negli ultimi anni
nel 2000 un pannello fotovoltaico
costava 5 euro a watt
oggi costa 0,5 euro a watt anche meno e
le tendenze sono chiare le linee rosse
rappresentano il costo dell'energia
dell'energia elettrica in bolletta la
fascia grigia il costo dell energia da
fotovoltaico
poi ci sono altre tendenze tecnico
economiche ad esempio su gli
accumulatori energetici che nei sistemi
afflitte sono fondamentali per diciamo
organizzare la discontinuità delle fonti
rinnovabili
questa è la giga factory che tesla
motors e panasonic che stanno costruendo
in nevada per raddoppiare la produzione
mondiale di batterie al litio e ridurne
il costo del del 30 per cento
ma ci sono anche altre sperimentazioni
su gli accumulatori ad esempio ad aria
compressa
noi con i miei colleghi ne stiamo
sviluppando uno poi c'è un problema
tecnico di adeguare gli edifici pensati
on grid verso lo script e qui è nata
l'idea
con i miei colleghi che poi abbiamo
brevettato di semplificare al massimo
queste operazioni la flic box è un
piccolo contenere alto due metri che
contiene all'interno tutti gli impianti
necessari a scollegare un edificio dalle
reti quindi pannelli fotovoltaici eolico
e batterie per l'elettricità trattamento
e raccolta dell'acqua piovana solare
termico calda e biomasse pompe di calore
per riscaldare e l'obiettivo era quello
di rendere accessibile e facilmente
comprensibile con una con un solo
impianto il modo di scollegarsi da dalle
reti di farlo con poche ore di
installazione e con una sola connessione
appunto di integrare al meglio tra tra
loro le varie fonti rinnovabili e di
farlo costare poco perché un box di
questo tipo costa meno rispetto ad
installare i vari impianti all'interno
dell'edificio e poi visto che era un
container è anche facilmente
trasportabile quindi abbiamo trovato le
prime applicazioni in zone remote ossia
in quelle zone dove le reti non c'erano
e quindi lo script era l'unica
possibilità questo è una zona rurale del
sudafrica dove in questo asilo abbiamo
portato elettricità raccolta e
depurazione dell'acqua e acqua calda
quest'altra è un'isola delle filippine
dove il tifone di un anno fa aveva
distrutto le le reti dell'elettricità e
dell'acqua e questo particolare of the
box a un sistema di dissalazione
all'interno quindi per produrre acqua
potabile da acqua di mare integralmente
alimentato da fonti rinnovabili ed è
stato possibile portarlo sull'isola con
una semplice barca di pescatori
ecco altre installazioni sono state
fatte e qua in italia su foresterie
oppure abitazioni private
quello che voglio dire che questo
progetto è solo un esempio di come
alcune barriere che impediscono
l'accesso ad un modo più sostenibile di
approvvigionarsi delle risorse possono
essere superate integrando creatività e
tecnica e sicuramente ci sarà bisogno di
integrare tante proprio professionalità
sia creative che tecniche per portare
avanti questo progetto o altri che
possono nascere in in altri posti per un
modello di sviluppo veramente
sostenibile
il messaggio che voglio lasciare questo
servono energie e intelligenze connesse
per andare of the grid
grazie